Te rechazan una solicitud de financiación,
las culturas no crecen, tus cohetes se estrellan,
nadie quiere publicar tu novela fantástica sobre una escuela para magos.
O tal vez es solo que no encuentras la solución al problema en que trabajas.
Y, estar atascado así,
puede producir estancamiento, estrés, posiblemente incluso depresión.
Pero, si tienes otro proyecto que te entusiasma y te desafía,
estar atascado con uno, no es más que la oportunidad de hacer otra cosa.
Todos podemos atascarnos a veces, incluso Albert Einstein.
Diez años después de ese año original y milagroso del que les hablé,
Einstein estaba juntando las piezas de su teoría de la relatividad general,
su mayor logro.
Y estaba agotado.
Así que se abocó a un problema más fácil:
propuso la emisión estimulada de radiación
que, como algunos de Uds. sabrán, es el principio de funcionamiento del láser.
Así que está estableciendo la base teórica para el rayo láser.
Y luego, mientras hace eso, vuelve a la relatividad general
y se siente renovado.
Ve lo que implica la teoría:
que el universo no está estático;
se está expandiendo.
Es una idea tan asombrosa
que a Einstein le lleva años poder creer en ella.
Si cuando estás atascado
eres capaz de poner en movimiento la teoría de los rayos láser,
estás en muy buena forma.
(Risas)
Y ese es el argumento para la multitarea en cámara lenta.
No estoy prometiendo que los va a convertir en Einstein,
ni siquiera en Michael Crichton,
pero es un poderoso instrumento para organizar nuestra vida creativa.
Pero hay un problema.
¿Cómo hacer para que todos estos proyectos se vuelvan completamente abrumadores?
¿Cómo mantener todas estas ideas organizadas en nuestra mente?
Bueno, aquí hay una solución simple.
Una solución práctica de la gran coreógrafa estadounidense Twyla Tharp.
Durante las últimas décadas ella ha desdibujado los límites,
ha mezclado géneros, ha ganado premios.
Ha bailado todo tipo de música, desde Philip Glass hasta Billy Joel.
Ha escrito tres libros.
Practica la multitarea en cámara lenta; no cabe ninguna duda.
Ella dice: “Hay que ser todas las cosas.”
¿Por qué excluir algo?
Hay que serlo todo.”
Tharp tiene un método para evitar que todos estos proyectos diferentes
se vuelvan abrumadores,
y es muy simple.
Le asigna a cada proyecto una caja grande de cartón,
escribe el nombre del proyecto en el costado de la caja,
y ahí adentro mete DVDs,
libros, recortes de revistas, programas de teatro, objetos;
realmente cualquier cosa que constituya una fuente de inspiración creativa.
Y escribe: “La caja significa que nunca tengo que preocuparme por olvidarme.
Uno de los mayores temores para una persona creativa
es que se le pierda una idea brillante
por no anotarla y ponerla en un lugar seguro.
A mí eso no me preocupa, porque sé dónde encontrarla.
Está todo en la caja”.
Se pueden organizar muchas ideas así, ya sea en cajas físicas
o en sus equivalentes digitales.
Así que me gustaría instarlos a adoptar el arte de la multitarea en cámara lenta,
no porque tengan prisa, sino porque no tienen ninguna prisa.
Y quisiera darles un último ejemplo.
Mi ejemplo favorito:
Charles Darwin.
Un hombre que practicó la multitarea lenta de una forma tan asombrosa
que necesito un diagrama para explicarles todo.
Sabemos qué hacía Darwin en cada momento de su vida
porque los investigadores en creatividad Howard Gruber y Sarah Davis
han analizado sus diarios y cuadernos.
Cuando terminó la escuela a los 18 años, estaba interesado en dos campos:
la zoología y la geología.
Enseguida se inscribió para ser el naturalista a bordo del Beagle.
Este es el barco que, durante cinco años,
dio la vuelta al mundo por los océanos del sur,
deteniéndose en las Galápagos, pasando por el Océano Índico.
A bordo del Beagle, Darwin empieza a investigar los arrecifes de coral.
Esto es una gran sinergia entre sus dos intereses, la zoología y la geología,
y comienza a hacerle pensar en los procesos lentos.
Pero, cuando vuelve del viaje,
sus áreas de interés comienzan a abarcar más y más:
psicología, botánica.
Por el resto de su vida, oscila entre estos diferentes campos
sin abandonar completamente ninguno.
En 1837, comienza a trabajar en dos proyectos muy interesantes.
Uno son las lombrices de tierra.
El otro, un pequeño cuaderno que titula:
“La transmutación de las especies”.
Luego Darwin empieza a estudiar mi materia, la economía.
Lee un libro del economista Thomas Malthus
y, en un instante, tiene su momento Eureka.
Se da cuenta de cómo las especies podrían aparecer y evolucionar lentamente
a través de este proceso de la supervivencia del más apto.
Se le ocurre todo y lo escribe todo,
cada elemento importante de la teoría de la evolución,
en ese cuaderno.
Y entonces...
un nuevo proyecto.
Nace su hijo William.
Es un experimento natural al alcance de la mano,
la oportunidad de observar el desarrollo de un bebé humano.
Inmediatamente, Darwin empieza a tomar notas.
Todavía sigue trabajando en la teoría de la evolución
además del desarrollo del bebé humano.
Pero, durante todo esto,
se da cuenta de que no sabe lo suficiente sobre taxonomía.
Entonces comienza a estudiar eso, y al final pasa ocho años
convirtiéndose en el principal experto mundial
en percebes.
Luego “La selección natural”,
un libro en el que trabajará por el resto de su vida.
Nunca lo termina.
“El origen de las especies” es finalmente publicado
20 años después de que Darwin presentara los elementos básicos.
Luego, “El origen del hombre”, un libro controvertido.
Y luego...
el libro sobre el desarrollo del bebé humano,
para el que se inspiró viendo a su hijo William
que gateaba delante suyo por el piso de la habitación.
William tenía 37 años cuando se publicó el libro.
Y, durante todo ese tiempo, Darwin trabaja con las lombrices de tierra.
Llena su sala de billar
con lombrices de tierra en recipientes con tapa de vidrio,
las ilumina para ver si responden,
les pone un hierro caliente al lado a ver si se alejan,
mastica tabaco y...
(Sopla)
les sopla encima para ver si tienen sentido del olfato.
Incluso toca el fagot para las lombrices.
Me gusta pensar en este gran hombre
cuando está cansado, estresado
ansioso por la recepción de su libro, “El origen del hombre”.
Cualquiera de nosotros
se metería en Facebook o encendería la televisión.
Darwin iba a la sala de billar
para relajarse estudiando intensamente las lombrices de tierra.
Y es por eso que es apropiado que una de sus últimas grandes obras sea:
“La formación del manto vegetal por la acción de las lombrices”.
(Risas)
Trabajó en ese libro
durante 44 años.
Ya no vivimos en el siglo XIX.
No creo que ninguno de nosotros
pudiera trabajar en nuestros proyectos creativos o científicos
durante 44 años.
Pero tenemos algo que aprender
de quienes dominaron la multitarea en cámara lenta,
desde Einstein y Darwin
hasta Michael Crichton y Twyla Tharp.
El mundo moderno parece ofrecernos una elección.
Si no estamos dispuestos a saltar de una ventana del navegador a la otra,
tenemos que vivir como un ermitaño.
Si nos enfocamos en una cosa, tenemos que excluir todo lo demás.
Creo que es un falso dilema.
Podemos hacer que la multitarea funcione y libere nuestra creatividad natural.
Solo tenemos que ralentizarla.
Entonces...
Hagan una lista de sus proyectos,
dejen a un lado el teléfono,
agarren un par de cajas de cartón
y pónganse a trabajar.
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)